Oh
[Music]
I don't know is it is it [ __ ] a bunch in
knowledge it's it's like a it's like a
you do like there's a lot of there's
like a lot of you know what I'll just be
Lu be gone we'll going on there you go
anyways it's an anime stream we got
lucky and we have or you want that all
right I mean you can write into it
straight into it so this is my my anime
OC that I've created
striking a jojo pose we got jump jump
force access yep a bit early and we
thought we'd show it to you guys yeah so
we're gonna go through some of story and
then we'll do some verses we'll just do
some hot matches we'll do you know
matches that you guys want to see maybe
we'll do like a one-piece versus someone
else I'm gonna like Yugi and like our
piece I'm Yugi there you go yeah you're
very excited for you not I said he
shouldn't be in the game you're I'm
legit like I don't understand it doesn't
make sense you know yeah that's that's
fair
so the setup basically we're kind of
early on in the story what's happened is
my my character got got by Frieza and we
had to revive them and now they're a
hero this lobby music is is a real
banger and I've joined the jump force
and now I'm part of this crew of anime
boys and girls who go around trying to
free their friends from the control of
these weird cubes but that's that's
kinda where we are so right now we're
going around and we're trying to recruit
people we've got all these who do you
think these correspond to we're really
gonna go through quite a few of them
yeah oh the Pegasus Knight is that like
part of the Yugi saga is that you guys
is that you you think well Pegasus is in
but he's not a Pegasus Knight I don't
know well we can find out or you can do
bleach cuz the substitute Shinigami
oh I'll hit up bleach after this yeah oh
it's Sasuke we get to hang out with with
Sasuke
here we go so some of the stuff is voice
text and some of it isn't okay these are
just kind of like the small quick like
skirmishes that you do people are under
the control of cue we got to go to New
York break on are we two lovers alright
alright yeah yeah throw out all your
favorite animes we also were gonna if
the game in town hook pass and if we're
gonna talk about who was missing and all
that stuff or who you want that's not in
so you almost have like a very one-piece
aesthetic I do so so it's like a it's
like a metal gear yeah one piece
when's when the game starts off and you
bake your character there are three
different fighting styles and say do you
want to fight like on bonanza
you want to fight like a pirate do you
want to play this game gets loud but
yeah out there now oh yeah you're
basically Luffy yeah well so you get one
move from all the people
oh I thought you're pairing all that I
was like that's pretty good
so I also know you got yeah I think or
Chidori
rather sorry cuz I know that you get you
start off and you get one move from each
of the captains okay that's how you kind
of like start off I also have a little
oh okay I thought you were doing that
other move that you had which was looked
like potentially it was Sanji's move but
I couldn't read it all yeah I need
meliora sex-bomb that is that is a good
shout I'd love some seven deadly sins in
here so that I was also talking before
we started astray really the rocks are
so big
we're also talking about how the the
season pass has nine characters that
they're adding and I really hope they're
all not like different forms of Goku I
want some like real nish
now that's what Dragon fighters is for
yeah people are speculating like there's
got to be like another one coming like
where's shaggy it didn't even take five
minutes there it is the memes all right
so you have hasta only one from black
over that's fair I guess believe she got
four you got Ichigo
you got Rukia you got Renji and Aizen
sure the Death Note people aren't
playable yeah they're only story right
and flippin Ryu doesn't even have voice
acting that's weak
yeah see like how come how can the Death
Note folks not be in but you I guess I
guess they don't have really moves he
really just writes in a book and people
yeah you didn't know that anyways
boruto from boruto naruto next
generation is obviously a city hunter
there's Rio that's that's the like Bruce
what Jeb the anime Bruce Willis that I
was talking about that it's a shounen
jump from 85 to 91 I love him so we'll
see him later Dragon Ball of course you
got some Goku Vegeta trunks piccolo
Frieza and self you got Dragon Quest
character you got die yeah yeah
you have Kenshiro from Fist of the North
Star Hunter x Hunter
shadow hunter x hunter gone freaks you
got Kilauea you got Kuro pika and you
have Hisoka Jojo for the Jojo lovers
yeah there's some Jojo lovers out there
there John Rose real good in the skins
Otero and do non-playable characters
Death Note
Light Yagami and Ryoga as we had just
spoken about my heroes only got one
character now I'm gonna guess they're
gonna get more do we know the season
past people no I don't think we know any
of the season past people yet well you
get Deku or sukhumi Torreya Naruto's got
five you got Naruto you got Sasuke you
got Kakashi
oh yeah Kaguya in this game thing yeah
and then Gaara that's kind of random
there must be enough people that like
Gaara that yeah I don't know then you
got one piece shoutouts to the Pirates
out there you got monkey Dee Luffy you
got
Renault Zorro Sanji yeah Szabo you have
Bowa Hancock because you know for the
Donna you got to you have and you have a
black beard and then Kenshin pension I
have not watched Kenshin a while if you
haven't you should watch like some of
the OVAs those are really good but you
have pension and then you have a she she
okay and then from st. SIA you have
Pegasus ayah which I guess I should have
knew from your Pegasus Knight thing and
Jack dragon shoot and from it's time to
duel
you have of course Yugi moto or
yami-yugi and then you have to show one
of the animes I grew up watching on the
toon honest mmm you have you see a and
younger Tagore oh and then original junk
characters you have Galena and ping
[Music]
joints that was more than half of my ELF
vengeful outlaw says Cara is the man oh
this is this is as if as it should be he
is he took away so much of my health
getsuga tensho
yikes anyway we're gonna retry that
fight yeah there's there's a lot there's
a lot of characters in here and someone
mentioned the the scenes aren't voice
acted some of them are and some of them
are it's a real kind of Jacques a split
where you've got like your side missions
and your main missions and the side
missions are all just written out and
the the actual like proper story stuff
is all there that's all good that's
where all the main the meat of the story
is as it should be but
well gets a good tensho just run right
through the lock though oh right miss
get out of here all right guard break or
something yeah so if you charge up your
heavy attacks you can break through
guards yes an actual knock you better
knock people back - that was a waste
just now that Ben's gonna work no later
but it'll be a fun time regardless yeah
we're here for just hanging out and
playing some cool anime characters how's
it feel it feels much better okay I
haven't played a little bit during the
beta yes so the the thing for me was I
kind of like I played this like an e3
event like years ago like packs or
something it's a block it's it feels
much better than it did back then so I
feel like we took a lot of like baby
feedback brought it back and made it a
bit better if I had Joe to row this is
do you think no I don't think so the
other thing too is with these fights
your characters actually have levels and
it takes him into consideration so I
might have because I jumped past a few
maybe it's like a little bit higher but
shouldn't be too bad she says it's
likely that the core audience was gonna
buy this game anyway so no Matt no
amount of voice acting would have
convinced non-fans this is a very super
like super super fantasy game so yeah I
don't know if it plays better than my
hero I'm already that's already a plus
because I wanted my hero to be better
and it just wasn't what I wanted I guess
considering I played a lot of tailings
in the past like in the same thing oh
yeah it is it was a Sanji's hit their
counter no this is not looking good yeah
this is Merrill you can do it
call Oregon Otacon okay okay here comes
to come back oh no does he if you know
if you do a proper time counter you can
actually follow it up with like three
counter hits Wow which are very strong
okay I'm gonna do this one more time
then we'll go back and we're supposed to
do okay just to keep it going so you
want to sit here and fight bleach all
day why do do we want actually know you
fight bleach all day until you get to
the one art where it should have ended
and then it didn't end right for it it
was glowing a guy I know who to play
against spent later
is there one be warned not it's a team
fight oh right yeah it's three on three
though I think most of the time in the
story missions you're doing like one
round fights against
ah my favorite move organ murder here
have a spirit gun that didn't hate oh
good ooh
but those those a real good read felt
very good about night it felt very good
watching it it's just the computer yeah
I know right
I went right for it look okay I was
doing 12 back then please throw him or
something cuz now you scathed like in
his demon form let me get that clearly
wanted a guard break so all you have to
do to really win this fight is just not
hit any buttons when he's countering and
I guarantee everything will be fine
three except for when he does that which
I don't even know what he did hollow
form he did that that's the move those
seven finish so even though I had a move
coming out so there's two supers then so
there's there's your like super ultimate
move and then there's like a powered up
one that you do after you do your
awakening okay so there's like multiple
tiers to vengeful outlaw I would take
some Tokyo ghoul characters give me some
kaneki just give me kaneki that's good
enough right you know I mean you can
have toka or something but definitely
need Kenickie I've got a lot of points
for trying that's
[Music]
who's the dragonknight when is this
coming out it's coming out Friday Friday
right yeah 15 ah going after that other
silly the armored man he's a saint just
like you I'll save my swear it
listen to me director Glover that's the
best character in this game they put
Glover in here that's the the most most
important part
what about Mortal Kombat I'm excited for
Mortal Kombat and it's pure beta yeah
another combat cast this Thursday yeah
it is kaneki from jump Oh caution is
Tokyo she forgotten his sworn oath come
back to his senses he's being
mind-controlled it is in weekly young
jump does that count
that sounds like a gym part of is media
so the light novel was are there any
issues with control
no I'm actually taking how they're
working out oh he's got super armor on
got that armor attack he does have a
shield okay Coco is very much a very
much a
there we go oh yeah go low I don't like
that leveled up his armor oh no I wanna
bring his pal out here fight it friendly
yeah then I'm gonna power my armor up oh
you got the wings Pegasus hit that
meteor fists with a lot of range I know
nothing about this character I don't
know anything okay the computer is
really bad with the loaded up heavies
and oh no rising dragon punch okay
oh yes the armor no there we know you
know he got me yeah you got got it's
okay you guys second second
you want us to play all I'm probably not
gonna happen there are a lot of people
running around and playing though I'm
sure I'm sure
a lot of people a lot of people doing
their thing
Oh fairy tale is another good show but
it's not I guess it's not shounen jump
man mikkel some Natsu some gray yeah
okay it's like a weird reset thing but
I'll take it
[Music]
have been play Kenshiro well he's in
story right now we can always go to like
the match stuff in they also have some
like some free matches and stuff too
okay
got a views that then they're weak
they're weak to it's true this this is
the thing just keep it going the Red
Hawk got him before you got there he was
not only anime game yeah yeah controls
got a battle royale game coming out soon
Zack asking does it work like universe
where you learn different moves from
different characters as you go in and
it's very very similar to xenoverse
which is really cool I haven't gotten a
chance to learn anything yet cuz I'm so
early on mm-hmm but I'm very excited to
pick some moves up Rogge probably later
this week as the is the whole plan we
just got it like a late late last night
how about Ginn tomorrow huh yeah yeah
yeah that's a good call I'm a big fan of
that oh korosensei yes i don't he should
in theory be overpowered but that's
totally fine in this in this case well
done all of you
you can have wait are you talking about
well Robin is definitely is not in the
game but if you want him honor maybe Bo
Hancock is in the game though yeah there
there are a lot of at least a few
costume parts that I've seen that are
kind of like ah Nami is not in the game
but you can buy her pants and heard like
he never know she could be in this story
or something yeah am i living under a
rock
not knowing Saint Seiya yeah my my anre
cred just went out the window
it's re I don't know about it more of a
role akahl like a like a surface level
nerd with that anime also I just
realized PIP stood on the left I wonder
if that's okay ah it's do wha
I can't believe what I'm seeing with my
eyes for ones in these gosh darn cars
passing on ones craft let's give it a go
okay get to bring trunks along there's a
lot of weird disturbing revelations I've
had with this game not like I didn't
realize that trunks his jacket was a
jean jacket oh really
yeah I thought it was just like a like
just a regular coat the man's got some
tile but it's weird to see like real
textures put on the anime characters is
what I'm trying to get at for some
reason they make their feet get dirty
when they run around like I don't know
if I needed that either okay yeah
there's no way I would have watched this
86 to 90 oh it's our boy
oh he's possessed Kenshiro as punishment
the cube has has gotten to him we got to
beat the cube out of him come on trunks
it might be possible that they're gonna
put all my Bakugan Oh chucka I'd be very
into that I don't know that's too many
from my hero though if there's only nine
that we know I could see one of the nine
maybe two of the nine going to my hair
it does one punch me on that count he
might not be can't put a character
that's got a one-hit kill in this game
that's he proved to you that in certain
cases it wasn't one here right yeah
that's fair I see someone asking I
forgot I didn't see the name of it but
someone's asking what her favorite
current running animation
Cody it was Cody Cody Cody Cody Asche an
odd promise Neverland casual I guess
I'll go with black clover or if not
black clover I'm watching sword art
Alice ization oh shoot prepare yourself
well said no can't sure I'll get out of
here shirt blue guess you can you can do
some like which is kind of nice yes
trunks I get like the longer strings you
guys send you to heaven he's trying to
are there like Auto combos in this game
so it's kind of like it's like a weird
cross between the micro game and the
Naruto games yes this is the way that I
describe it so it's got like you've got
your main combo that's when you're just
hitting X or Y and then if you press up
or down it'll chain off into a different
type of thing it'll take them up or down
so there's variety in there but it's
it's not the depth I think comes more
from like the the countering and
blocking and dodging stuff yeah you've
also got like a stamina meter that lets
you get out of combos whenever you want
which is really nice a big fan of that
no reviews till probably later this week
again as mentioned for us we only got
last night so I love cute oh and like
Hasina in the game but who knows you
never know yeah ken-chan so toxically
masculine like is i don't know if this
is I'm sure it's from some point in the
anime but I like this designer he's got
like more armor on his arm
I've been playing a lot of the the
Yakuza one like that a lot to give me
some I can't say the aura from Bleach
it's here I can probably do because they
also have these free missions that you
can do where you can bring anyone you
want to to fight what do these give you
so it's just kind of like a way to level
characters up in between main fights
okay look at the roster yeah we could we
can look at every single character
that's in here I think unless this is
just who I have no this is every single
one I'm going to probably take take my
OC I'm gonna take John Rowe and I'm
gonna take let's take my new favorite
look at hard look at him I'm gonna watch
this anime now okay I believe it he's
just sweats you see him in action he's
real good
Yami Don Chao maybe maybe game God who
knows
what do you think about the story ask
monkey Dee Luffy dang uh it's it's
there's a lot of weird like kind of what
they did for Smash Bros thing in
ultimate where it's like ah your
favorite anime characters but turn into
bad guys and their eyes are red fight
them to get them back and there isn't I
don't see much of an overarching thing
yet but I think there's something going
on in the light because he's just
showing up and is just kind of doing it
so I wonder if he's got like this
ultimate plan going on or something
ooh got some Dragon Balls stuff going on
right now I can't make the noise but
yeah I love you Lupe's Empire I'm also
kind of like following Bruce Lee one one
piece
that is such a law of midori anime where
they really got some of those old-school
roots where I feel like they kind of you
know drag episodes out a bit yeah and
they do a lot of recap in the beginning
and journos so cool what are you where
are you looking at he says oh don't
dance so good always shot guns down oh
oh he's got you serious now not serious
enough and no love with her pika
oh he's about to unleash the powers of
his football anime danny tanner's here -
trust
did you eat breakfast oh oh I got you
have X Y Z I have this yes boy it's
stupid I love it so much he's a
professional sweeper tell me you don't
want to watch this anime now whatever it
is I for me it's hard to go back to some
of the old stuff yeah that's the only
trouble from the insistent
being so used to the animations of today
that well I'll take him to space anime
dad it's time yeah
as for people asking about the review
probably later this week oh no that's
why this is okay oh you lost your sweet
shirt now you're really diehard yeah all
right
you just gotta lose your shoes now oh my
god
very angry you getting serious I might
be no I countered him take him down oh
shoot
sigh I didn't know you could do that in
the air the counter yeah yeah like rock
paper scissors oh so it's multiple
around okay I thought it was just by
character death but it's like if you
lose one
oh no sorry one life bar for all three
right oh my god our full rocket launcher
stance
no man can hold two rocket launches like
that only in anime yeah oh shoot a
speech watch your toes
oh sure heartily out of there
ha ha ha high-octane gameplay where's
Metro oh let's do this length yeah that
is a level one so this is like his
ultimate like his like final finishing
oh ok but it's very good Oh quick
chopped bullseye
you should be deflecting all your shots
el dead whoa
what's your anime knee what would your
Anna name knee anime name be oh wow look
at all the level ups I got from that
that was no no no crime that's tough
I've never really thought about this I
usually pick like a color and oh shoot
apparently there's a Jackie Chan movie
by the name of City Hunter that might be
based off of an anime oh really
well bauxite is asking if it is but I
didn't even know there was a Jackie Chan
movie now watch that because if there's
a Jackie Chan playing that guy was
apparently making a new city hunter too
she's moving maybe that's why they put
him in here to kind of give everyone a
heads up about him yeah I'm monkey Dee
Luffy the predate to me I don't know
anything about that anime I openly
admitted it to it so you know I also
don't know too much about it if anyone
could tell me what what's on the GPS for
Xbox one yeah we're playing on PC and
AUV your ass later yeah I'm going to
summon Exodia oh yeah cuz i don't i
don't have deal yet so this is this
isn't even the full roster that i have
oh really
yeah but you said inverses everyone the
longer versus everyone's there
so the one Naruto character I like
because I know who he is I know
No nah rito is oh you mean you just like
Kakashi you just you're all about the 1i
uh one-eyed but also I like the fact
that he's like a ninja who's very aloof
and reads arrow gay novels like a
romance novels not arrogant offals
whichever there mm-hmm
no Tokyo ghoul characters at least that
we know about oh that's a good one
darkness that's what devil fruit would
you have if you could have your own made
oh man oh it has to be like one that
doesn't exist in the world oh I don't
know that's such a tough one because
you'd want to pick something that like
oh man cuz kind of curry like he has but
like I said like the mochi fruit like
what all this [ __ ] is based on all of
its like based off of like mochi like
his moves are all mochi mochi mochi no
need yeah see so it's uh because his has
so many applications like more so than
because he's like one of the strongest
you guys didn't know who he was but
those who watch or read probably know
who he is
oh man I don't know I really don't this
guy Blackbeard's got a crazy one too I
forget what his devil fruit is but he
has like a crazy devil fruit too he
might have more than one though right is
that Marshall Marshall DT he definitely
has dr. hope is based off a rum anyways
he stole that that fruit by the way he
was never that strong until he stole it
we'll probably get more into like
character suggestions or oh we'll do
that in a second where we add 15 more
minutes and and like we'll just would
just play I don't like it
no boy yeah he's made a rubber man a
rubber hose cool he talks back there
yeah I think like that some of them have
lines for other characters yes you can't
be well this is like a later Luffy so
yeah this is definitely a way later
version of Oh Goods myself
trust no one not even yourself look that
you're the same color though and there's
no there's no alternate one yeah are you
the one we can tell each other apart now
because he has a shirt on yeah she chose
to fruit powers okay pick eysan i hate
eysan though oh I will pick Yugi don't
worry creaking what the water food not
actually hate I always had this I had
this argument
gadge about why he shouldn't be in the
game I'm like dude he summons cards that
are in an alternate universe at best and
even then like whatever
[Music]
you have you he has darkness fruit and
tremor fruit okay there you go
this East I forget for the people that
are like deep into the one piece how how
does he have the ability to have to do
it do it do it
Detroit smash we need korosensei I know
someone else had mentioned that Yugi is
soft yeah but do you mean the young UV
or do you mean like the Pharaoh
does he have zombie Maru or like that's
that is Anwar there you go bankai
oh no also if you haven't yet I want to
direct everyone's attention to all of
the signs they're hilarious
cabbage something it's kind of hard to
see sometimes but deserts win something
the theory layup shoot large like it's
just cloud they're just random things
that sound like things Andromeda I don't
even bring Zorro out at all I got caught
up in it
[Music]
so I think we got a few levels it might
be a good time to get the run back on
okay
yeah see we'll see where we are with it
key missions let's do it I'm gonna get
it we've got it this time
yeah it's Yugi moto and Yami Yugi
what about beyblade dude if I can let it
rip
how did they know I already send out
there beyblade um yeah it's been see the
like mystical animal that's in the
spinning top yeah yeah you've you're all
your moves are illegal beyblade mods
sure and I suppose all right
feeling it feeling it take them up
watch
the counter get the counter walk
what son get some spirit gun oh the run
back is real do it no okay
hopefully this does enough I don't know
though
wait for it no I went for it I can't
believe this
I'm gonna play if you go and do it
that's right it's right we had to give
him the one this time because this is
the one okay
he is this the main character this is
the strongest guy in his anime he so he
is the only character so far with the
move that does 75% damage and I'm real
stoked that I blocked that when it
happened he's had to he's had to beat a
lot of bad guys let's just say that wow
that has range nice
see you spamming your block over there
alarm removes pretty good greatest of
all time okay I'm gonna block this and
everything's gonna be fine I didn't even
make it to me
I'm just punch the air really quick to
make sure you know Louie boom there we
go hockey cheat you know anything about
his background he is a pretty
overpowered character
well how did you like transplant without
actually having a donation skipped the
the animation form but I didn't call my
my teammate to which I think you do if
you do it in the middle of a combo okay
last stop there you go that's a long
time there's got to be something you can
do there right there is actually I
probably would've been the option I just
got too scared that's fine he has
instilled fear within you what has that
counter there we go see it was fine it
was funny go one piece formula in that
show move to an island free the
oppressed massives move to another
island all while fighting their way
through it and and having to defeat some
hard and tough enemies oh he's got his
shirt back thank goodness he is a proper
gentleman it's true not as much of a
gentleman as animate Danny Tanner though
you love that boy I don't know what his
deal is but I love him so much
this is the most powerful witch you go
oh yeah that's why I said like he's
pretty much like in his final form oh
shoot well that explains it all
like when he splits his swords - that's
like another like thing he learns like
way down the road see is he older cuz
his face is very square I mean if he's
that version then sure okay
quite funny says I've completed the
story awesome have fun hanky is good
roll it was boring
Kenpachi and byakuya are more
interesting really I don't really find
byakuya that interesting Kenpachi I like
where is Don Quixote Don Flamingo
nee-sama be Akio from dong and raava
uh so how much longer before we gonna do
versus what you want to do mission
that's fine okay I just I wanna know if
you wanted to play I want to play let's
do it okay a trek I need time to evolve
here because I don't know I'm doing in
all honesty this is sync Tori it should
be okay yeah you're good are aware of my
buttons so you got a regular tech-heavy
attack at grab grab jump block and then
this is like your your - yeah and this
is your switch button okay I'm gonna see
it'll make sense when you get it it'll
be it'll be fine we don't pick at the
same time wow this is so you can counter
pick everything I do
well generally everyone yeah okay cuz
David was saying that he was worried
that he didn't see you know it's got its
do next to Joe like way to kind of show
it you know Stu Kenshiro and do you know
if you have to be at a certain spot in
this story to have access to everyone
because I don't think so
David says he doesn't see everyone he
says he's 13 characters uh if you got
yeah go to the vs. kiosk to actually see
it's time to do I'm really upset that it
doesn't have the English dub with the
really deep voice I play him with though
man
who speaks to you there's a lot of
people that speak to me I watched all of
these so we'll uh we'll do this one off
of who we want to play and then I'll
play this later
oh yeah okay there we go yeah we're fine
man do we play gone let's go we'll take
requests from people later on yeah let's
do uh do a fight and yeah oh so you do
unlock more levels to cuz San Francisco
wasn't their suite until I played their
hole is that the to Naruto like hokages
statues
it might be you're asking the wrong guy
all right so this is throw throw yeah
and that's jump
that's jump oh there's only Layton
immediate yeah light or light and heavy
I guess and you can also charge up both
of them and charging up your heavy is
what causes you to break through those
guards and then what's the dodge one
Dodge is right bumper and then moving
the stick and access to your special
ability is holding holding down our and
then any other face buttons well you can
you can kind of like see what's going
dude what time is it this guy died so
bad do you want a moment to this you
know I will learn on the fly all right
by summoning that's not a summon of some
sort Oh clear Dark Magician
oh this block yeah oh the camera switch
this is weird for me
oh I can draw cards yeah you got a draw
Oh all those swords are revealing right
it's it's random every time you you do
it so you don't know what actually comes
out of it you cannot beat yami-yugi ah
this is John Roku Joe you're talking
about not present oh this is why
[Music]
well you've already got your jacket
knocked off oh no oh no oh no use our
get out of there
no don't worry my trump card oh no it is
I Slifer the sky dragon Oh No you bet
that would never happen in Yugi's oh
shoot
quickly Yugi draw I'm blocking shoot oh
my god oh my god
time is moving so slowly we might need
to increase tap the round timer no we
don't know see we're ready to Chris I
really would switch their characters out
either whizzed we know who we want to be
well I'm just trying to like figure one
Oh No
beat him up no he's not meant for this
life heat stands all my cards are flying
everywhere
[Laughter]
what
[Music]
I drew nothing yeah I must say this is
the thing that's messing with me the
members I tried to draw again I was so
dumb that move is a thing time for Anna
me Danny Tanner to do a thing I'm so
sorry to the Yugi fans your point blank
shoot a kid yeah so if you if you you
tap it to cause them to come in yeah and
you can do like a combo with them or if
you hold it you can cause them to come
in and do an assist
so tap it okay okay I tap it to switch
my he beat the deck of cards out of my
hands yes this is true
don't worry oh we're gonna get him with
Slifer hello
that's a good question hello there we go
everything's fine uh all right so who do
people want to see I think you should
just play another match and then we'll
look then we'll get a list going well
I'm gonna give this guy ago since he
gave me so much trouble sake Ichigo
okay fanservice I like it
we're mixing it up or trying to try to
switch off you know what I've always
liked piccolo a lot and that big big
piccolo fan all right his light no he's
not playable he shows up in the story
I'm really curious if they don't try to
make him playable later on because of
everyone because I wanna I do it
yeah I'm trapped eyes and the one that's
gonna have to help you and we didn't
give us a fair shake boards all right
just keep them coming what we'll get to
them yeah yeah oh let's go to Japan
please Vegeta I can do that
please Vegeta so all 40 were unlocked
for you at all times you said four
inverses because I'm just you know what
David was mentioned I believe
ooh I'll take a do next time - I got
Vegeta in do for the next one this
shouldn't take long
she's scary
it's real scary outcome won't change
who's that thingy alone
excuse me so I packed to go maybe
everyone has armor on
they're heavy charge maybe yeah yeah
yeah yeah all right yep
get that midair tag too
thank you okay don't know what I'm doing
clearly just mashing at this point so if
you time it it's it's you time when the
hit knows and you press our Barbie you
can get a counterpart oh god oh god
there's so there's so much happening
almighty push whoa oh I've got a debuff
now your clothes are really ripped yeah
I didn't save me with your woof powers
it's pick loads all right okay so you
have to hold right trigger and like
actually
oh that's that's a spiders move yes see
that's that's kind of nice about playing
fighters as I can oh I put up a wall
even though I haven't played like
watched much so I kind of recognize
these okay so you keep pressing X you'll
actually follow up with a notice for
that no this is this is cannon hasta oh
my god you've got a big sword too come
on I've got the answer to this I'm a
demon now there on the half a minute I'm
also a demon I hit first
what are you ready cuz I'm ready I don't
know I just did oh never mind I'm not
ready
get it yeah get it okay not bad second
game yeah I I don't even know how I'm
doing that - away Wow boy it's Hancock's
got some costume that was me as
destroyed as it can be anyway
ya think
alright so what did we miss all right
let me do Vegeta I'm gonna do do who
else was there so playing as a flying
girl no I don't have a what oh that was
cocky yeah yeah I guess that's true
boruto Kakashi Ichigo what oh my god
Aizen and I screwed him up
I did a Bakke the grappler he's not in
here
Kenshin
boa fanservice all about that plot I'll
do I'll do burrito burrito I got my my
people set up been too good with each Oh
he's not too hard to be good with so I
grab do you did what choose Naruto
alright
oh there you go you get Naruto and
burrito I'm your dad Jason Naruto but
he's not even Hokage Naruto he come ish
to turn him it was scary
thanks for trying eyes yeah I didn't do
a good job I gotta figure this out it's
not as um yeah I know the combos aren't
the way I think they would work but I'm
also not doing a lot of things right so
the Vegeta do combination it's coming at
you so do you try to combo into your
right trigger moves or is that not even
a today so you can with certain ones but
what I try to do is the you can press
forward or backward to change your combo
up like mid combo and it'll cause you
like if you press up you'll launch them
into the air and then you can do like an
egg to switch them around okay this is
Oh God I don't know how to do that
take him to space guys at the time yeah
yeah it's all with the right bumper like
any any blocking or covering is with
right bumper and getting out of combos
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah so how do you counter
them so if you're about to hit or about
to get hit you tap right bumper and it
will do a howl you just type Rep okay
if you want to block you have to hold it
down but tapping is banded and then left
bumper is your like if you're in the
middle of a combo getting hit you can
press left bumper to get out of it
gotcha
okay which really helps to like that but
it uses up your standard oh no that
crunchy noise yeah yeah that's not a
good sound
yep Oh Kenshin what yeah poor Canton oh
[Music]
no son is beating up the - trying to
make us a canon fight right they do do
the training and sparring all the time
actually I should probably ideal because
I want to do Oh or armor I think I was
doing that charge me I need to hit more
to do yeah now we're good
[Music]
although no the world it's perfect
[Music]
there is only me so you get that like I
ultimate then so press right trigger and
a it should be
[Music]
but she did like nothing heavenly flying
dragon knocked my shirt off though
that's the thing all right there were
two of me as sheathing I got a spandex
more I'm really I'm really stoked about
the Jojo characters they're really doing
it for me
you get bad boys girls versus even worse
what is that oh no I'm gonna be I'm
gonna give this guy ago all right
Blackbeard I'm picking enemy Danny
Tanner because no one's asked for him I
don't think they will you know yeah
there we go yeah I love that it sounds
like it's straight from the anime I'm
very into it it's a burrito beats dad
it's it's where we were Sanji thong so I
I most of my one-piece knowledge comes
from playing the mousou games so I'm
really confused when he goes from doing
kicks all the time to like smooching at
people
I played Eisen earlier I just played
Kenshiro terribly oh yeah no one's
picked goku yet or monkey chute
I can pick monkey is Jojo a good anime
yes bauxite highly suggested
that's right not on you lose why that's
small nerd just stopped me from punching
him there are some things that shouldn't
be made with realistic textures
sometimes we play games bring me alone
get a man read Danny Tanner Oh
substitute enemies good actually
you got real quiet all of a sudden I
don't know if I like you I'm trying to
figure stuff out I got it oh that thing
has two mouths why ancient Egyptian god
oh did it actually hit oh wow 100 hits
must shoot you from downrange it's too
far
ah it's not too far for you though
oh gosh Sanji son here's some jambalaya
oh wow you're inside the ice cube yes
target Whammer scammed oh I got you just
let a little bit oh my gosh
oh no I'm pressing buttons they block it
no I got hit
oh it's hurt like bankai rook lab that I
found gene Kisaragi in this game how
dare you swords of revealing light your
card nonsense
[Music]
kawaii
she's thrown throwing kisses oh no you
got a good set no oh God
oh wait is that is that because he's
funny against oh yeah gurmann okay so it
changes just like everything else okay
see that's good I'm into that Oh Oh God
you followed me in have some
[Music]
yes oh no what is what does that even do
what am i doing yeah
oh my gosh please please dinner one time
all right
[Music]
okay so I can shoot guns in the in the
air in the swords yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah no no oh no the
third dance there are all yeah yeah yeah
I don't like it yes
No
screw it going in there I don't know
what's doing oh boy grab your head and
shoot you with a gun oh no yikes
big yikes she character taint carrot yep
Sandy's proving out on Rukia that's
correct
oh man he's totally cool with the bleach
fighters
Wow Rukia yeah Rukia was not this strong
in the anime that's for sure let's try
this boy table yeah look he's friends
with Luffy and ace he's actually pretty
buff and spoilers he inherits ace power
oh I'll pick sauce guy Sasuke and I did
not believe in the heart of cards that's
right I did not chant it enough so
spring out baloney Kenshin baloney
baloney tension did you pick okay
I did not pick the right mr. Zorro I
keep picking Zorro and I never actually
get to fight Zorro because I never
switched to him which is a weird thing
I can't avenge yourself I'm on the right
playin Goku Hisoka and Zorro and bends
on the left and he's gonna destroy me no
I mean you'reyou're no no no I like
don't know what I'm doing I'm like
there's too many buttons I'm like
alright you're getting the point where
was the first round with with you II I
actually kind of got worried I was like
oh god am I just what's happening this
is marine poor big fight here
let's have ourselves a fight oh he's got
what the white and I'm with her eyes
what can he do or that who is this
character sword fighter on sword fighter
this is uh this is pretty legit I'm
gonna do it this is just a Soul Calibur
match
what excuse me
there we go okay
she's got a big angry fire punch oh no
dang it so I just sidestepped that thing
oh there's another whoa it's blowing up
where am i what is he's a nursing boy
it's got like a like a cane pipe Oh God
oh no that was a counter I went right
for it
oh the immediate counter oh my god I I
thought sauce guy was a ninja oh hi
spider ups you and say hello give me the
gum
oh no the fire boys Chidori me with the
fire I pressed the wrong button that's
like day one he's pretty all right sauce
guy stop it
you're triggering me you're triggering
Chet I'm gonna give sell ago so I know
he doesn't sand things and it can show
again yeah it's a real weird
disproportionate setup when there are a
lot of really cool characters that could
have put in not been to New Zealand
there's a giant shipwreck there that's
pretty cool he's touring me
yeah well he was G Dorian he was doing a
Chidori and I added the ing to it it's
it becomes a verb at that point the
final catch up we'll never know
feels bad yeah well you know Ben had at
least one to two hours with the game
it's true I've got a little bit of
practice can I do a head of everything
with the girl in the red shirt is his
original character you get to make a
character yeah yeah she gets you to make
an OC - it's a fight with everyone why
I'm pressing block game
[Applause]
okay I can't interrupt you all so I
think you have to go a brief through
your own charged attack yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so that I would have to
try to hit the block button
yeah right at the right time yeah we're
on the beach this is my natural habitat
this is where I'm best at why doesn't my
third dance come out good Oh imbues
attack okay yeah so now you you like
make me cool what do you hit me
oh you have food
yikes no I literally just swap
characters okay oh God
what if we didn't do that
yes aim holy cow
almighty push yikes
uh yeah also same put you in the sand
coffin except it's way back there for
some reason
Cagayan was brought us back in the game
Oh Naruto
Oh No bankai
oh no it's so cold it's okay now my
shirts off now you know I mean business
what is going on it's it's happening oh
yeah yeah so not good I try to interrupt
it no no no
I can do that too come on please hit
your back off though Oh what are you
doing Oh like am this come back here
oh no the time stamp is definitely a
ranged character
yikes do we do we want to go back and
change the timer yeah I think that's I
think that's a fair cause I got I don't
I don't know I think too much apex
legends how do you play this game
where's my slide well there's my guns oh
you just see it please enemy Danny
tanner
great legal makes sense Oh No Limit
there we go okay the people want Madera
yeah he'd be OPA I'm gonna pick my OC
didn't gotten picked at all
go with played the Saints I agree I'll
pick one of them I'll pick one on to you
I'll take dragon guy here you I I'll
take it protagonist
Pegasus see no one's been killable yet
and let's uh don't think anyone's pick
midoriya yeah yeah we'll pick that good
yeah oh let's just go to the it's pretty
fluid d-mac it's a little confusing
though sometimes it gets kind of crazy
when yeah once you get through the
actual tutorial like it's not as good -
you while you're attacking so psycnet so
you hold down right bumper and then you
press left to right so basically I'm
here the left stick yeah when you're
when you're blocking any direction you
push will let you go like forward
backward okay I need that because you're
getting me at that heavier yeah avoiding
it she doesn't say anything that's fine
let's guess build more RAM they make you
pick a voice I don't have any lines I
can do that - oh God barely hit my head
okay with my OC is very strong they have
tens in every step this is not true once
you with a real hand oh no I did not
want to use this all whatever but it
works I think they do more maybe only
certain attacks have a lot of damage
I don't understand it entirely oh
goodness
dude - away Oh No
I always dashing so I definitely got
caught it's not good you're not Sanji
you're not signed it's not it's true I'm
not it's it's Meryl layered - but see it
thanks her for hanging out your attack
faster don't know it's a special need to
not do that dosnt your pain no thousand
years of pain that's what he's supposed
to do I feel like I'm missing on
something now cuz I know exactly what
that means and it's not what I'm getting
I don't know I was so ahead and I don't
know he he went into shutting so how do
you activate getting the right stick
when you've got half your picture filled
up it was like a weird hit call yeah
there's like a weird head meter that
puts you into awakening mode ultra
instinct which is the thing I'm gonna be
the freezer would be bring him back and
I'm gonna give him ago I should just be
playing as Joan Roland to try enemy
Danny Tanner out it's a good time it's
not my he's not my aesthetic that's fair
where's 200 or something my aesthetic
I'm very in there I know no one's played
dice oh I'll play him there you go oh no
I know I marquise I failed this you get
all f9 then alt f9 again yes just to
like started to start a new one for the
last 10 or so minutes so good the real
the real matches you know I should add
shaggy everyone wants that ssgss shaggy
look at him so confident he'll never
look this good again
oh you have them too you bet okay to to
gun dad's I uh no oh I always doing that
oh shoot
I'm just gonna I just tried to change
there you go
shotgun take him up take him up
[Music]
take them up
oh shoot hi dad
no this is the strongest move I can do
Ben
oh god this is the strongest I can do
nice and then oh oh now he's thick
freezer
so where's the stamina meter same
another circle okay so I have to have a
whole thing of that to do that dog
I don't think you've done where do I
stayed Nick the whole time
Oh God oh come on
looking back point at you and your
rocket launcher I hit you with it stuff
I don't know which one I am
oh you're hitting me jeez it's all part
of my plan this is why you told me to
pick him Oh God I do like that he can
shoot dodge do it Oh No
Jonnie Jonnie Your Dragon Quest
what about yeah the shotgun what some
type of aura man think about everyone on
my team looks real real busted up here
that one booth I'm shocked there's no
KarenT color though yeah it seems really
not good it's a very odd choice because
you can't have a mirror match basically
especially the way the camera works get
in the top ah skip that let's do that
guy and you're all played I'll play you
V okay forgive you you go I was in for
piecing your console it's on PC Xbox and
ps4 we're playing on PC right now though
right and no one no one's picked yeah
oh wow we're one piece in his his GD
team uh let's go to Paris it's lovely
I'm really stoked that the anime
terminators here
sytem on mob I don't think so but yeah
that's another thing spaz is talking
about the music
I'm there's like no iconic themes
anywhere I'm gonna be the Pirate King I
believe in you you can you can do it
it's maybe not today
oh my god this guy is disgusting serious
centimeters thank dodging and dashing
losses up your standard joys
what Juliet
she might be too strong no no no this is
all part of my plan
yeah ha ha we win chat what will happen
all right bring you yeah yeah draw yep
[Music]
God where all my clothes go Oh No
I just wanted to play Magic the
Gathering with my friends Oh No I'm
still your little charging you're fine
this is fine give it back to him oh no
excuse me
Bonzo mine comfortable with whatever is
happening oh no Joe Joe no oh come on
pistol no you're too far away you're too
far away no I don't have any Sabo why
can't you peez thank you oh yes oh you
ran from him
yes we've aided him running around the
map
you can say
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
a wonderful way to make that last seems
like it should oh it's funny because I
kept squat shopping huh hey yeah yeah
you want to do this charge it up no you
had me oh shoot bond oh man
Oh take it more right
Oh what is the shooting out of his arms
his gomu gomu God you at the star finger
what that one was the gomu gomu no
didn't do anything
nothing let's do one okay
whoo oh yeah I don't know I'm I got a
pink yeah you got - I got a pick since
the last one I got to pick all my people
okay not my OC though which I feel bad
for for leaving them out
all right Ichigo show off the element
types and how abilities so I haven't
played my stuff enough to be able to
tell where that stuff all kind of comes
into play yet I've seen D buffs and all
that all the hidden leaf village is
right there you know what let's uh let's
do it I don't think we've been there yet
come on yeah I don't know I'm gonna
figure out what it was I I did right
trigger B so we'll see what that one was
man I'm not I'm definitely not typed
tapping the right bumper at the right
time it's it's a weird time for it like
the windows seems pretty tight
yeah the Dragonball RPG game I gotta
figure out what ichigo's counter is
that's all we have oh shoot your Ichigo
it's not even realized that's all we got
oh boy how to unlock characters so in
verses the are seemingly unlock from the
get-go at least from these ones at the
heaven take it up take it up take up
tensho I will figure this counter it's
got to be one of the three buttons go
take him up yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
shotgun
I see your mystical tornado and I
thought you'd pull my gun out but I
couldn't exactly I feel the same way
hasta oh I'm already Dean where's the
guy with the gun from he's from like an
anime that was in the eighties I've
never heard of it until this game very
India Oh
from downtown what I countered that
which our boards overall I read that
like an open book
[Music]
nice good it's not good chat it's not
good chat no one more one Adam yeah so
you said rights stick right cooking the
right step must not have had it it's so
it's when you're the little thing around
your portrait is either half full or all
the way full I have full uses it up
quicker because there's less meter to
burn through but I feel like I guess
level three it just has like a box or a
zoom regardless yeah it's a really weird
place for a meter to be
what Josh my bullet
oh my god coming up Tim I need you to
stop for a second whatever you're doing
you've logged into the matrix you need
to log out no it's my turn on the Xbox
get out of here oh yes good barley go
unchecked we had to unleash loopy yo ha
no delayed it
everyone's on the field let's do it no
okay I was gonna say it that won't work
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay okay nice until I'm dead I'm turbo
dead there's no way out of it
oh no thanks for letting me have one
like that thanks I swear all right is
that it's one one oh yeah this is this
is for all the marbles I just had to run
up counter that's that's my tactic there
that counter when I was locked in doing
my it's like watching a train wreck like
oh yeah
I do like that it has like the the combo
guard there so if you get like over
seven hits you just a silly pirate kid
Oh boom honored my honor that was too
good
oh shoot I like oh we both did at the
same time get em children live through
it you're awake into loopy so good so
good with the need okay I know how dare
he call him a pirate kid he's The Pirate
King
[Music]
what just happened I think you switched
your carrot I know but even where you
[Music]
going you're those years calc calculate
little years of time that you sat there
with that up can't believe this excuse
me you're too far away why are you
pressing buttons yes cause we go like
this I get something out before it
happened
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah grab him break on
yeah it's not good check
[Music]
oh no I was actually trying to counter
him but didn't show with all we had I
was I was even I was like oh god the
counters gotta be happening oh yeah
we're split it's right around time the
last one
[Music]
[Music]
do it do it do it do it do it yeah
it's just so much damage random
please get that I think I'm blowing I
hope I'm talking I'm not blocking this
is the last stand
I don't know if we're gonna make it chat
cuz I don't know what to do after this
to do they're like on the heavy I think
I'm supposed to grab him so yeah I think
you can grab her you can do your own
charge the charge has its own armor
there you go oh yeah
nice work nice work we got there chat
loopy loopy was the only way I think
good good you would been a pirate kid
damming it yeah it's I mean comb-like I
see him yeah that's fine
review for jumpers probably later this
week can't promise that but I think
that's the plan or hopefully there's a
lot of big games coming out the 15th
this jump for us as well coming out on
the 15th we have more streams this week
far cry new dawn I believe later this
week also Metro Exodus probably gonna do
some anthem at some point hopefully
because that comes out to 15th - I feel
like I'm forgetting something else that
comes out to 15 I said far cry Metro
jump horse Oh crackdown 3 crackdown yeah
yeah I don't know if we're gonna stream
that one only because we just have such
a huge slate of game so much so do but
hope you guys enjoyed it thanks again
been for whooping me at any time I did
not play UT rights there were good voice
should be in the game good fights I good
time yeah and who's your against Emma
probably your yeah good talk you could
have it get Kentucky into this game
again yeah he needs to be here I take
fairy tale or kaneki from Tokyo cool
but anyways until next time peace
[Music]